[Music]
Cyprus is add opening yeah but it makes
me think of that sketch because he's
wearing that Jersey football jersey it
makes me think of the sketch of Key &
Peele
but yes weird names for the football
players oh yes Cypress Jackson you think
of that I'm Hannah Riley I'm Blake yeah
do they both have a speech impediment
yeah they do that thing where they speak
with her to the front and like a lisp
yeah it's a speech impediment to talk
beard
[Laughter]
[ __ ] - yeah he got Sam Smith and Cisco
I wanna make a correction according to
Janet Sam Smith
he's gender-neutral right he lives on a
spectrum I'm talking about 2015 Sam
Smith thank you my behalf
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
am i ugly no I think you're very very
attractive oh well she wants to eat him
up everything about her posture in the
Weasleys like oh she's he's gonna smash
and just by looking at his face I think
he's gonna smash in - if I could tell
you I could give you like a letter of
the alphabet that defines you I would
give you eat yum we match these two on
purpose yeah I actually like girls with
lips because they already just sound
like they're wet
like what is that thing that you want me
to do with you I hear a lisp on
likeagirl warning everyone I'm a real
like lightweight so I'm a real
lightweight
[Laughter]
you have to hit it down we have to do it
again chase you have to do it
he's definitely atop the way he told him
what to do in the other guys like okay
okay what's your type and am I your type
you are attractive though you might be
my time I don't know
my type is usually tall guys with facial
hair imagine is being offered free
drinks being paid to be there and being
offered a freeze Lake like this is what
this happening right now
Wow can you make it you know she strikes
me out she strikes me as like a hot girl
but very conservative hot girl I could
tell you know she gets around he gets
around so good for them
wasn't that a Beach Boys song I get
around these to get around sound do you
make when you make it
okay that's the one I've always had the
Lisp thing yeah yeah I'm mad at you
imagine trying to give a dry BJ with a
lisp that's right BJ what yeah
you know I mean like you know some girls
they just do it'll dry they don't know
what they do it
but if you have a lisp it's gotta be
moist in there it sounds like they have
to say moist with a lisp mostly has it
really sound like it's moist with
African you know that's pretty common
[Music]
where's the craziest place well I don't
know if this is like necessarily crazy
but I hooked up with my ex-boyfriend in
a bathroom of a hotel room and his
parents are like in the room
you know we just they're asleep second
uber one time no you didn't know she's
like no you didn't that I totally want
to do this to you sorry but that's gross
it's one thing to do it in your cars one
thing you do in your hotel room with
your parents there but to do it in
someone you pay for
that's gross yeah measure your voyage
flip the genders try to make fun of the
girls I told you she was conservative
I seen bras like this like really
attractive broads who take care of
themself nothing wrong with it but you
can't I like them say I have to be like
in a relationship right good for you
girl but that's what she strikes media
amateur I think it's real it's not as
like a theatrical and like obnoxious I'm
with her on that I'm not mad I don't
want HD stuff at all anymore
too much fake the core value and Luther
the core value of fun everything about
those dudes is just screaming
inter-dimensional what the core value
what you know
doesn't make it flirtin hard I'm
respected though she's Anissa he's a
low-key dude this is a good one because
this is easy which one of us do you
think is more attractive yes is she
gonna be like bust off grumbling be
between the two of us who's more
attractive oh definitely I think she I
think you saw it yeah same here
based off like her track that Lisp is
driving I cannot get over that list I
don't know any girls who got lists I
slide my DMS you know I mean cuz you'll
be sliding really easily with that Lisp
right bro they're not gonna slide
release this you're gonna slice really I
love it
well I think she doesn't believe that
but she's a nice person so she's just
which one of us do you think is more
attractive I did not believe one word
she said become that's why he my face yo
you're not good at this it's like you're
so conservative you can't even live
proper what killed me was that she said
I think it's you
he's like word it's like you're supposed
to say back to me so I'm gonna take that
back that's what it feels like
she's been clowning him since the
beginning that's a thing that's a girl
she loves good she tastes herself but
she's conservative so whenever she's in
that position she's gonna clown the
other person have you ever had a
threesome and would you if not that's so
excited he's like man she probably does
but stuff yeah
whenever you're gonna be a little freaky
like how much more freaky do you really
get you answered so if you won't do it
just do it you're paying for watching a
shop she's a good girl she wouldn't have
just said no answer you answered I'm
sorry mom her taking that shot maybe she
didn't do it
it looks like he's proposing it to her
yeah I did so I did for booties about a
five son that's a lot of people it's not
an orgy at that point yeah I don't see
the appeal on that like last thing I
want to do when I go see another [ __ ]
naked yeah y-you hear one thing I've
never thought of when I was feels like
damn you know what make this better more
what point do you say yes what I eat
what I hate we'll prime is the DP yeah
when it is in the same like notation
yeah and I'm like okay let's most
important one right would you like to go
out on another date
you're attractive first of all you're
funny thank you I like your smile no
that's a no it's like one of those
things where I'm like I'm open to it but
I'm not that attractive would you like
to go another day oh we could yeah I
like these two
yeah they cool I like him a lot just
person anyways but her her list she's
perfect next Tuesday Ilana all right
next Thursday go home I go four to five
to shake on it
sure take a shot on wait can we take a
shot on it I made a new friend
whoa cancellation it's done it's not
even good listen you're not in you don't
want it you don't want it I think preach
you were right yeah it's a it's a yes
but it was enough it was a no that's
enough that's here
maybe boyfriend is a bad flirt ah the
poor blood she's one of those flirts
that never gives it up just get all
misty papa
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay how would you rate your orals
skills I'm with myself a video oh you
wanna start this again
you think I got the bottle the hole okay
you should always give yourself a ten
you probably never do get out of here
you probably went to you this girl gives
the worst there's girls I guarantee you
this girl gives such bad BJ's push out
here give myself a tent but you're so
pretty [ __ ] they're not gonna tell you
suck but I guarantee you she's terrible
she gives VJs the same way someone would
suck a lollipop that they don't like are
we done yeah yeah no she gives BJ's the
same way she gives people like
confirmations for dates like yes but
maybe yes maybe yes maybe not that was
today's video it was good I like this
concept yeah I like that I like the
people they cast you and if I find them
sometimes a little weirder detestable I
think it adds good flavor they're real
people you know they're not just
caricatures or whatever that's what I do
yeah it was a good video do you want add
no no very good well that's it for today
we want to hear your thoughts which
couple did you like the best which video
what part of this made you cringe and
ladies if you had a list pile at me
that's pretty much it and don't forget
to subscribe to the patreon
[Music]
you